hey guys i'm jeff keely producer of the
game awards and curator of summer game
fest and i'm going to answer 20
questions
[Music]
good questions let me think i gotta get
known for this i mean it has to be hideo
kojima doesn't it as a leading question
lucy
hey i didn't say any names out there i
didn't throw any names
what did you predict
i would predict it i was uh i was like
slightly suspicious that we might get a
surprise joseph ferris in there but you
stuck to your guns you stuck your guns i
respect it
[Music]
oh wow that's a very deep question i
would probably say my favorite muppet is
beaker
mimi you know there's just something i
just love his
his sense of life he's just a sense of
adventure with beaker he's always just
trying things he never gives up he even
though you know bunsen will put him
through the ringer he just is like
springing his step ready for the next
experiments and just never never down
never out of it and i was so
so excited when we finally got to have
beaker at the game awards it was one of
one of my life highlights
wow great question i i have to credit my
stylist jin yang who picks my sneakers
out um i would say
i like the ones that we had at game
awards 2020 were sort of the all blue
ones that were pretty cool um because
right around among us there was like
always got the among us drip and yeah
those are probably the most uh most
stand out stickers to date but
we'll see what we have for summer game
[Music]
that's really hard to pick i would
probably say
uh the first year when
we got to give our industry icon award
to ken and roberta williams who were
childhood heroes of mine for sierra
online a lot of their adventure games um
that was really sort of special for me
and there were a few other moments that
year that were amazing like the koji
kondo and magic dragons but uh
emotionally probably that was the the
highlight for me
[Music]
we'll go with living i think i would
honestly we haven't had miyamoto on um
summer game fest or game awards we work
with them a little bit when you're at
the video game or it's spike but yeah i
would love to have we've had miyamoto in
the show but not in person so i think
that would be pretty cool to have him
he's just
so fun and lively and yeah it hasn't
happened yet
x but
why more of a night person i mean this
time of year i probably go to bed around
like 12 to 1
um most nights and then i don't know i'm
up at like 6 6 30 so probably around 5-6
hours sleep normally
i get that question a lot and it's hard
to say but i
i would probably go back to some of the
adventure games of my youth like monkey
island 2 was very special to me
there's also a game called gabriel
knight that i got to be a beta tester on
that was one of my favorites so um i
don't yeah i am biased towards pc
adventure games because that's really
where i first fell in love with the
industry
question one meal for the rest of my
life what would it be
um i would i love a great strawberry
so i probably just like a bowl of
strawberries
is that a meal though are you not having
anything else on that do you want some
cream you can make it eating mess yeah
that'd be nice yeah that's very british
yeah i yeah i i yeah i have some
strawberries and cream maybe throw in
some blueberries like that yeah i just
like i'm feeling like the fresh fruit
right now for some reason yeah i don't
know i have that like that one favorite
meal but it's definitely like i just
love a there's some berries
in los angeles place called harry's
berries these amazing strawberries like
the best strawberries in the world
and the meme time capsule um
i'm trying to think i don't know the one
that's my current twitter profile that
was somewhere i was kind of watching the
eldering trailer last year that was kind
of like that's that's a that's a
positive fun one yeah i don't know it's
like and obviously there's like the you
know doritos gate that i don't feel like
a decade ago that one but i would say
yeah i'd go with the elven ring uh
the wow face
[Music]
wow favorite music album ever uh
i really like arcade fire the suburbs um
that's one of my favorite bands that's a
good album that's hard to pick but yeah
i'd probably go with that
uh i added an adobe premiere uh it's
what i learned when i was a kid in
college and stuff like that and yeah
premiere after effects has been my uh
what i edit my stuff
i do we've been talking to them uh i
don't know exactly you know uh what's
what but i think i think they were
actually hit hit pretty hard by the
pandemic um it's a small team and stuff
like that and so they've been taking
their time but yeah we check in with all
these teams all the time so i don't you
know i say we've talked to them i don't
know exactly what the state of the game
is or where they're at things like that
but yeah we're i would love to showcase
that game when they are when they are
are ready they did uh they did like an
edge cover it was like a year or two ago
and then didn't really put any more out
on it so i don't know where they're at
on that but uh yeah we've certainly
talked to those guys and team cherry is
a
great studio and uh we'd love to work
with them at some point
[Music]
been a long time that was
2015 i want to say or something like
that the hydro bot yeah hyder robot
taking it to the next level that was
sick
um i think i think uh the night of the
game awards probably the last time i
spoke to the hyderabad i don't think
hyderabad actually speaks so i might
have just like waved at his blade or
something like that hydrobot is gonna
school me on how to protect my skin from
irritation
kyle's amazing uh we love kyle he was uh
i think he started as like an intern or
a pa on my spike show at game trailers
and i just loved him so much i'm like
let's put him on camera he was on camera
for the first time for i think was the
playstation 4
reveal in 2013 and everyone in the
office was like don't put him on camera
what are you doing and i love kyle i
wish i wish more people
got exposed to cows like such a talented
incredible individual he's streaming on
twitch all the time we work with them on
all my shows and yeah
love boston
the thing i'm most excited about well
sort of two vectors i think i'm really
excited about kind of emergent
storytelling and the idea that you know
narrative games that i love
uh ai and neural networks i think will
allow them to sort of evolve in
interesting ways where the dialogue of
characters might actually change um
throughout the game and i think that's
really interesting to think about that
you know i would have a different last
experience than you would or something
uh and the other thing i'm really
interested in is a lot of stuff i've
been doing with fortnite like the big
event i did with jj abrams a couple
years ago for star wars and these ideas
these sort of big mass social events in
um you know
gaming worlds i think there's something
really interesting to that um that is is
kind of a
point of interest for me as a creator
and a programmer of content sort of like
what could i do with that so that's the
other aspect of it
[Music]
solid state 100 nailed it well done
you know i have not in full disclosure i
have not played smash in a couple years
but um i there's something about kirby
that i love
that down smash
is pretty good yeah i feel like i feel
like kirby is like
you know new game this year i'm not
not a huge smash player i haven't played
in a couple years but yeah kirby was
probably my most frequent
great question i think it's figuring out
like the most relevant option like we've
had some insane acts that have wanted to
play game awards but in the past they
just it hasn't worked out because they
don't have a link to um games yeah i
mean like sting last year was insane um
i don't know it's a really good question
i don't know i have that sort of dream
act their acts that we've talked to i'd
love to do something with arcade fire
one year we've talked to them over the
years about stuff um it's never quite
worked out but i love that band so that
would be a fun one so i guess they would
probably be the one there's a uk art
it's called dave who has a song called
verdance vidents yes which is
yeah yeah i saw david coachella like
about a month ago he could be great for
it i would love to do music stuff it's
always actually really a struggle to
find out who to book because it's just
they have to have a relationship to the
gaming world and have a game that
they're working on and stuff so yeah i
love like going to a concert this
weekend a festival it's like i love
music so i wish there was more of a link
there um but we'll see we we don't have
anyone booked yet for game awards so
there's still time
yeah i mean trent we've we've tried i've
tried to get trent to do stuff for
years with us i wanted him to write a
theme for us one year yeah it's
it's been hard to get trent to uh he's
turned me down a few times so um yeah
we're hopeful that i would love at some
point to get um him or nine schnails i'm
actually gonna see nine chanels this
weekend which i'm excited about i'm up
in boston so um yeah i would love to get
them uh to do the show one year
thanks for watching guys and make sure
to check out summer game fest when it
streams
live on thursday june the 9th at 11 a.m
pacific 2 pm eastern 6 p.m gmt
on gamespot